[Musique]
c'est les 60 premières secondes quand
bref a été diffusée sur le grand journal
ça a été assez fou comme moment parce
que c'est un moment qui a vraiment
changé ma vie
quand on a créé serge le mytho et qu'à
un moment donné on était vraiment mort
de rire devant les conneries que
jonathan disait sur le tournage on
pleurait de rire
et en plus on pouvait pas couper la
caméra donc on a pleuré de rire pendant
45 minutes
donc c'est 60 x 45 les moments les plus
drôles de ma vie
vous êtes un moment donné où jusqu'à la
poste
exactement ce qui se passe quand je fais
une soirée je m'amuse 60 secondes et
après pendant trois heures je sais plus
ce que je fais là je me rappelle quand
j'avais 18 ans 19 ans tu savais pas quoi
que tu sors de chez toi qui a commencé à
faire la fête mais un peu plus de
manière plus avancées déjà tu rentre pas
chez tes parents tu peux rester la nuit
chez tes potes tu vraiment il ya une
vraiment une sorte d'hymne à la liberté
tu kiffes de ouf je pense que c'est la
meilleure serait ta vie et après tout ce
que tu fais ta vie c'est de dire
j'aimerais retrouver ce flash du début
mais tu te retrouves jamais il faut être
félé soit je disais pourquoi j'ai vu
cette soirée jourd'hui restait dormir ça
a été mieux j'ai la chance d'avoir un
super chien quand je suis allé chercher
une portée de jeunes chiots de dix jours
et je n'ai pris pas mal dans mes bras il
est tout ça un peu en train de chialer
je suis ok sympa et yann un jeu les prix
et dans mes bras et c'est nsc l arrêter
de pleurer c'est là je me suis dit bah
c'est ma chienne et et on va passer la
vie ensemble et voilà des bergers
australiens meilleur chien du monde
à l'époque on recevait les quarts mais
les carnets de notes aller à la poste
donc dans la boîte aux lettres pouvait
aller chercher le courrier a avancé par
an et c'est ce que j'ai fait je
cherchais mon carnet forcément je le
plante j'attends encore deux trois jours
et ce en dehors de trois jours de
liberté en plus parce que franchement le
carnet lamentable je vais me faire
laminer
ça va être plus de playstation plus de
consoles plus rien suis sur mon père
rentre à la maison il est où ton carnet
g j'en ai pas et commencent à
m'engueuler et où est ma mère prend ma
défense
le 10 mai un fêtard est d'anglais ton
fils croit le il te dis la vérité là tu
vois bien je les regardais quand j'ai vu
la déception de ma mère la 17e les
détruit qu'à ce moment là bannière genre
une fille ce moment et en plus le carnet
a été pourrie c'était horrible tout dire
et tout le combo là dedans c'est que
t'es à côté quelqu'un de thèmes il se
passe rien et tu te dis bah c'est ça
l'amour en fête se passe rien mais c'est
général
j'ai sept ans je suis à la piscine et
avec tous mes potes et tout je suis le
petit de la bande donc moi j'ai des
flotteurs parce que je sais pas nager
les petit flotteur orange et je me dis
qu'est ce qui se passe si je mets mes
flotteurs autour de mes pieds donc je
prends un flotteur je le mets deuxième
flotteur je le mets et qu'est ce qui se
passe en ce moment la boucle inverse et
je suis souvent en 3 me noyer quoi donc
gros coup de chance j'ai temps d'un
petit bain donc j'avais réussi à me
repousser et voilà par rapport à
d'autres gens dans le monde je me rends
compte que ma vie est pas si dangereuse
que ça c'est quand quelqu'un vient boire
dans la rue et me parle pendant une
minute et me dit que ce que je fais
c'est cool et ça lui apporte des trucs
vraiment bien dans la vie et ça m'arrive
souvent ils croient que suis très
chanceux dans ma vie
[Musique]